All right.
Many people who want to get on with me today,
I want to hear from some of them.
Let's go first here to Marta from Miami, Florida.
Marta, what is on your mind today?
Hello.
Yes, I can.
Oh.
Well, what about.
I live in Miami, Florida.
Most.
Martha, you're cutting in and out.
All right, so so we you're I can barely hear
you.
I heard you live in Miami and then you immediately
cut out.
So most of my family's Cuban-American and
they keep using the argument that Biden is
a communist and he's a socialist.
And I just want to know, what can I say to
them or do you have, like, a good article
you can recommend just so I can like you?
But the argument.
Listen, I have not seen anybody seriously
be able to answer the question, which Biden
policy is a socialist policy.
So I'd be curious if you were to say, OK,
let's let's actually examine that.
What Biden policy is a socialist policy.
Usually that falls apart and then they move
on to a different argument, which maybe would
be easier to deal with.
Yeah, because I tell them I'm like, you know,
it's not it's going to be like that.
I don't know, it's gonna be like Cuba and
we're gonna be, you know, struggling for food.
Secondly, I like listen, I mean, what did
I say to them?
Was it like Cuba when Barack Obama was president
for eight years?
Because Joe Biden was the vice president.
If it wasn't like Cuba during those eight
years, why would it be like that under Joe
Biden?
Yes.
And then they bring up, you know, the whole
Cuban missile crisis.
And Kennedy and it's just what I don't know
what to do with Joe Biden.
What?
You know, I think in a lot of these here,
what you're getting to, Marta, is that in
a lot of these situations, it's not really
about you explaining the truth.
It's about just coming up with something to
say so they can perpetuate their own misunderstandings.
And you might I mean, it could go that way.
It could go Biden's a socialist.
And you say, well, what's one socialist policy?
They say, well, it's just it's going to become
like Cuba.
And then you would say, well, was it like
Cuba when Obama was president?
And then they would say, yeah, but look at
what Kennedy did during the Cuban missile
crisis.
Now we're 50 years ago, right?
It's they don't really want to know anything.
And sometimes you have to just acknowledge
that.
Yeah, that's basically been the exact argument
for months and months and months, is that
I don't envy you, Marta.
And, you know, the people who are calling
in and may not know the American Hispanic
community is a very left wing community in
total.
But the most conservative subsection of Latin
Americans is Cuban-Americans.
And it is usually this reflexive anti Castro
thing that the ones who came to the U.S. were
against the Castro regime.
They associate the Castro regime with Democrats.
Why?
I don't know.
And you end up in situations like Martha's
situation.
OK, thank you very much.
All right, great to hear from you, Martha.
Appreciate appreciate
the call.